cette nonne les chroniques de la haine
ordinaire
[Musique]
bavarois
avec le dictionnaire de la bêtise devait
jeter les carrières récemment réédité
chez robert laffont l'incitent le pdi
des idées reçues de claude valette me
semble constituer l'un des ouvrages les
plus importants de cette fin de siècle
dans le domaine de la culture daigné
zante
on y apprend entre autre certitude à
réviser que lindbergh ne fut pas le
premier à traverser l'atlantique par la
voie aérienne ça y est ça il fut le 67e
parfaitement il fut le premier à l'avoir
fait en solitaire sans même une hôtesse
pour lui peloter les genoux est bon je
compatis mais 64 aéronautes ensemble et
en ballon et deux aviateurs en couple
avaient réussi avant lui cette équipe
est casse gueule au dessus des dents de
la mer
on y découvre encore que gutenberg n'a
pas inventé l'imprimerie
mais seulement la typographie c'est déjà
pas si mal je voudrais vous y voir
ou que le fameux élémentaire mon cher
watson attribuer un champ locals ne
figure dans aucun des cinquante six
romans de conan doyle un ascète vous en
bouche à quoi
ou même que jésus loin d'être fils
unique avec quatre frères dont il nous
parle à peu
car c'était un homme qui avait tendance
à ramener le suaire à lui
mais là plus salutaires démystification
à laquelle se livrent claude valette est
sans conteste celle du mythe du lion en
tant que roi des animaux
se firent bestiaux couronné en prend
plein la gueule et avec lui tous ses
thuriféraires bea à commencer par jean
de la fontaine le chef de file des
lèches culs zoophiles versaillais dont
les clichés verbe pro léonins ne cesse d
garer nos progénitures sur les chemins
hasardeux de la connaissance en réalité
le lion est un gros con lâché coire
contrairement à d'autres félins moins
bien coté en brousse il ne chasse c'est
pas de moi je les piquets sur une
affiche de film s'il est rare que je
pique mais quand je dis que j'ai dit
c'est moi ça fait moins voleurs c'est
quand même du vol contrairement donc
dis-je à d'autres félins moins bien coté
en brousse il ne chasse pas seulement
pour se nourrir mais aussi pour le
simple plaisir de tuer comme n'importe
quel officier de carrière
et encore et encore à condition d'être
en bande et que le gibier soit malingre
on a vu ainsi des lions se mettre à six
pour massacrer un seul rockets sauvage
arthritique
comptez les mêmes proportions pour un
peloton d'exécution c'est bien ce que je
disais mon colonel
la plupart du temps le lion ne chasse
pas lui-même d'ailleurs il n'ya pas que
ça à faire il dort il laisse à sa
femelle le soin de chasser à sa place ou
bien il se planque derrière elle pour ne
pas prendre un mauvais coup de patte de
glue dans ces nobles couilles royal
la formidable puissance du lion lui
permettrait de foudroyer un zèbre
percheron en lui fracassant les
vertèbres cervicales d'un seul coup de
patte
mais il a bien trop peur de s'abîmer les
ongles
le terrible rugissement du lion qui a
impressionné des générations d'enfants
au cinéma les soirs de métro goldwin
meyer n'est pas destiné à subjuguer ni
pétrifié les animaux de la jungle le
lion ne rugit qu'en sortant de table ou
au moment de thrombine et une femelle
récalcitrantes lors d'un rite mal
compris en fait le rugissement du lion
n'est au mieux qu'un raw et au pire qu
un couinement extatique d'éjaculation
précoce
pour achever de déboussoler cette
majesté usurpatrice claude valette nous
révèle qu on observait des lions
disputée aux vautours des restes de
cadavres grouillant de verre et repartir
la queue basse en faisant kai kai kai
pour un petit coup de bec dans le cul
en conclusion je déconseillerais aux
partisans des animaux de défense
l'acquisition d'un lion de garde pour
lutter contre la délinquance maghrébo
juvénile
certes une pancarte attention lieu
méchant peut s'avérer dissuasive mais le
lion outre qu'il est plus lâche qu'un
élastique de culotte petit bateau de la
femme canon
être au saut pour pouvoir vivre en
appartement ou dans un pavillon de
banlieue il est incapable de faire le
beau de donner la papatte ou de
rapporter la balle juste un con
en revanche le pot-au-feu de lyon et
délicieux
en voici d'ailleurs la recette que je
viens de déposer à la société des
auteurs en même temps que celle du
chihuahua melba
alors pour vous noté un vous prenez à
lyon
prenez un bouillon
quand et 900 kg pour 750 personnes
l'oeil doit être vif
bon plonger votre lyon dans l'eau
bouillante
quand l'eau frémit le lion aussi
s'il se sauver faites le revenir avec
une échalote
ajouté au bouillon un bouquet garni thym
laurier estragon laisser mijoter à feu
doux pendant deux heures en touillant
régulièrement la crinière ne doit pas
attaché
pour voir si le lion est cuit piqué lui
son gros cul avec une fourchette
normalement au bout de deux heures le
lion ne doit plus revenir
ce que le dicton bantous exprime fort
politiquement lyon bullion foutu
à toutes fins utiles je signale aux
éventuels lecteurs que j'aurai réussi à
appâter que l'encyclopédie des idées
reçues de claude valette est épuisée
depuis six ou sept ans mais brigitte
bardot aussi ça n'empêche pas de
continuer de bouffer du phoque
je
quant à ces féroces soldats je le dis
c'est pas pour fierté mais ils font rien
qu'à réussir nos campagnes
non non
[Musique]